so what we would do when we cut up the
uh the Rocks is we would put like a bag
and we call it shake it'd be like the
crumbs
she's like yo cuz let me get the crumbs
I was like all right cool whatever so I
give her the crumbs we hanging out there
now I was like man I want some weed he's
like [__] your cuz got some so I called
her I was like yo let me get some weed I
get the weed from we riding around we
listen to Tupac smoking I'm smoking he
doesn't smoke I'm smoking and I'm
listening to the music sound like it's
chasing me like it's like it's like it's
like it's I'm the most paranoid I've
been I think I'm gonna die he take me to
the hospital oh I'm sitting there when
they got me background so yo do you
think she put those crumbs in the weed
100 you feel what I'm saying to make it
more potent but I still didn't get the
truth out of them but that I stopped
smoking for like 10 years after that no
oh yeah that's [__] up yeah you got
lace till 10 years you stopped what it
was was I was I was more afraid because
a lot of my friends you know we started
on hustling you know a few of them
started smoking crack uh and by this
time I'm gonna need deep in it thank you